i'm now going to introduce you to the
notion of the efficiency of an engine
efficiency
of an engine and it's represented by the
greek letter eta
so even though it sounds like an e it
looks like a kind of funny looking n so
greek ladder ada this is efficiency and
efficiency as applies to engines is kind
of similar to the way we use the word in
our everyday life if i said how
efficient are you with your time i care
about what do you do in that hour that i
gave you if i said how efficient are you
with your money i'd say how much were
you able to buy with that hundred
dollars i gave you so efficiency with
the engine is the same thing what were
you able to do with the stuff that i
gave you so in an engine in the engine
world we define efficiency to be
the work you did
with the energy that i gave you to do
the work essentially and in our carno
world up here this is all the stuff i
had done before what was the energy that
i had given you
well the energy that i'd given you was
the energy that came from this first
reservoir up here remember when we were
removing when we were removing the
pebbles from a to b we were moving the
pebbles to keep it as a quasi-static
process so that we could go back if we
had to
so and and so that the system stayed in
equilibrium the whole time if we didn't
have this reservoir here the temperature
would have gone down because we're
expanding the volume and all of that so
we had to keep that reservoir there it
added heat to the system we figured out
this multiple times the heat added to
the system was q1 it was equivalent to
the work we did over that time period so
it would have been the whole shaded
region not just what's inside the circle
but so the heat that we gave you was q1
we later you later gave some heat back
when some work was done for you
but what we care about is the work is
the heat that we were given
so in this case would be q1
q1 and what was the work that you did
well the net work that you did was a
shaded area it was the area inside of
our carnot cycle so that's our
definition for efficiency it's always
going to be a fraction sometimes it's
given as a percentage where you just
want you know if this is 0.56 you would
call that 56 percent efficient which is
essentially saying you're able to
transfer 56
of the heat energy that you were given
and turn that into useful work and so it
makes sense at least in my head that
that that that would be the definition
for efficiency now let's see if we can
play around with this and and and see
how efficiency would play out with some
of the variables we're dealing with in
the carnot cycle so what was the work
that we did
well we know our definition of internal
energy our definition of internal energy
has been more useful than you would have
thought for such a simple equation
our change in internal energy is the
heat applied
the
the net heat applied to the system let's
be careful here let me call it the net
heat applied to the system
minus the work
minus the work done by the system
right now when you complete one carnot
cycle when you go from a all the way
around back to a and actually i'll make
a little side here you could have
actually gone the other way around the
cycle but if you went over when you go
when you go the way we went the first
time when you go clockwise you're a
carnot engine you're doing work and
you're transferring heat from t1 to t2
if you went around the other way around
the circle you'd be a carno essentially
would be a carno refrigerator where you
would have work being done to you and
i'll touch on this in a second and you
would be transferring energy the other
way and this will be important to our
proof of why the carnot engine is the
best engine at least theoretically from
an efficiency point of view if
efficiency is all you cared about but
anyway that's what i was talking about
so if i go a complete cycle in this pv
diagram and i end up back at a what's my
change in internal energy
it's zero my change my internal energy
is a state variable so my change
internal energy is zero my change in
entropy will also be zero it's another
state variable when i get from a back to
a
so over the course of this cycle we know
that my change in internal energy is
zero
what's my what's the net the net heat
applied to the system what's the net
heat applied to the system well we apply
q1
let me do it we applied q1 to the system
and then we took out q2
right we gave that to the second
reservoir we gave that down there to t2
that second reservoir and then minus
work
and all of this is equal to zero this is
the net i just want to make it clear
this is the net heat applied to our
system so the work done to this done by
the system we just take add w to both
sides of this equation you get w
is equal to
q1
minus q2 so there we have it let's just
substitute that back here
and instead of w we can write q1 minus
q2
as the numerator in our efficiency
definition and then the denominator is
still q1
and we could do a little bit of math
this simplifies this is q1 this is the
heat we put into it so it's the net heat
we applied to the system divided by the
heat we put into it so this is equal to
q1 divided by q1 is 1
minus q2
over
q1
so once again this is another
interesting definition of efficiency
they're all algebraic manipulations
using the definition of internal energy
and whatever else now let's see if we
can somehow relate efficiency to our
temperatures
let me this is q1 right there so what
were q2 and q1 what were they what were
their absolute values not not looking at
the signs of them i mean we know that it
was trans q2 was transferred out of the
system so if we said you know q2 in
terms of the energy applied to the
system it would be a negative number but
if we just wanted to know the magnitude
of q2 what would be in the magnitudes of
q1 well the magnitude of q1 let me draw
a new carnot
carnot cycle just for cleanliness
i'll draw a little small one over here
that's my volume axis that's my pressure
axis
p
v
i start here at some state and then i go
isothermally what's a good color for an
isothermal expansion
oh maybe purple it's kind of it's an
isothermal expansion i'm on a isothermal
isotherm here so i go down there and i
go to state
and i went down to state b so this is a
to b
and we know we're on isotherm we had
this is when q1 was added
this is when q1 was added this was an
isotherm if your if your temperature
didn't change your internal energy
didn't change and like i said before if
your internal energy is zero
then the heat applied to the system is
the same as the work you did they cancel
each other out that's why you got to
zero so this q1 that we applied to the
system it must be equal to the work we
did and the work we did is just the area
under this curve
we do this multiple times and why is it
the area of the curve because it's a
bunch of rectangles of pressure times
volume pressure times volume and then
you just add up all the rectangles an
infinite number of infinitely narrow
rectangles and you get the area
and what is that and just that's the
review pressure times volume was the
work right because we're expanding we're
expanding the cylinder
we're moving up that piston we're doing
force times distance so
the amount q1 is equal to that integral
the amount of work we did as well
it's equal to the integral
from v final all right let me i
shouldn't say v final
from v b from our volume at b
oh sorry not from our volume at a
to our volume at b we're starting here
and we're going to our volume at b
and we're taking the integral of
pressure
and i've done this multiple times but
i'll do it again pressure times our
change so the pressure our height times
our change in volume dv
we but we go back to our ideal gas
formula pv is equal to
n r t divide both sides by v and you get
p is equal to n
r t over v
and so you have q one
q
one is equal to the integral of v a from
v a to v b of this little thing over
here
n
r t over v dv
all of this stuff up here these are all
constants remember we're on an isotherm
our temperature isn't changing we could
write t1 there because that's our
temperature we're at t1 we're on a t1
isotherm right there because we're
touching the t1 reservoir but this is
all a constant so we can take it out of
the equation
and then this we've evaluated this
multiple times so i won't go into the
mechanics of the integral but so this is
q1 is equal to our constant terms
n
r
t 1
times this definite integral all we have
left in the integral is one over v the
anti-derivative of that is natural log
and then you evaluate at the two
boundaries so you get the natural log
natural log of vb minus va which is the
same thing as the natural log of vb
over va
fair enough this right here is q1 all
right now what is q2
q2 was this part of the carnot cycle
q2 was when we went from c
to d
right we went from c to d so that q 2
the magnitude of q 2 is the area under
this curve right here
it's the area under this curve
now this is the work done to the system
so that's why we subtracted it out when
we wanted to know the network done by
the system and we ended up with this
area over here when you subtracted this
as well over here on this side
but if we just want to know the
magnitude of q2 we just take the
integral we just take the integral under
this under this curve and what's the
integral under that curve
what's the inner this is the heat out of
the system
the heat that had to be pushed out of
the system as work was done to it
so that integral so we could just say
the magnitude of q2
q2
i'll do it over here
is equal to
the same exact logic applies we just the
boundaries are different we're now going
from and remember when we cared about
the direction i would say i'm going from
v c to v d but if i just want to know
the absolute value of that area because
i just want to know the magnitude i
could go from v d i could go from vc to
vd and just take the absolute value of
it or i could just go from vd to vc and
i'd get a positive a positive area so
let me just do that
so it's the integral from v
d to v
c
remember
the the cycle we went from v c to v d
but i just want the absolute value i
want this to be positive so i'm i'm i'm
turning it the other way
of p dv
and we do the exact same math there you
get q2
q2 is equal to n
r this time the temperature is t2 we're
on a t2 reservoir
times the natural log
times the natural log and this time
what's it going to be times the natural
log of
instead of vb over va
it's going to be
v
c
v c
divided by v d
v c divided by v d now let's use these
two pieces of information and substitute
them back into
that result for efficiency we just got
we just learned that we could also write
the efficiency of an engine to be equal
to 1
minus
q
let's look back at it 1 minus q2 over q1
1 minus q2 over q1
so let's substitute q2 there and q1 over
here and what do you get
you get the efficiency of your engine is
equal to 1 minus q2 is this expression
over here
n
r t 2 times the natural log
of vc over vd
all of that divided by
q1 which is this one over here and
our t1 times
the natural log of v b
over v a
now we can do a little bit of canceling
obviously the n and the r is canceled
that will cancel
and now we have these natural logs and
all that but i had a whole video
dedicated to show you
that vc over vd is equal to vb
over va
now if we know that these are equal then
this is equal to this so the natural
logs of them are equal so we can just
divide and what are we left with we're
left with the fact that
efficiency can also be written as
1 minus t2
over t1 4
for a carnot engine
for carnot engine remember this time you
know what we did over here this applied
to any engine this was just a little bit
of math and the definition of what of
what work is and and and well i won't go
too much into it right now but this is
for a carnot engine right because we did
a little bit of work here that involved
the carnot cycle but this is a pretty
important outcome because we're going to
show that the carnot engine in the next
video is actually the most efficient
engine that can ever be attained we have
to be very careful about that that when
we say efficient it means that between
two temperature sources you can't get a
more efficient engine between those two
temperature sources then the carnot
engine i'm not saying it's the best
engine or it's a practical engine or
you'd want it to power your your lawn
mower or your
your jet plane i'm just saying that it's
the most efficient engine between these
two temperature reservoirs and i'll show
you that in the next video